peu et dont vous avez fait votre
déclaration d'impôts vous laquelle mais
à celle de 62 alors moi je me suis
arrêté à 58 - pourquoi je me lassais
c'est ma femme vous savez quand même
remplir une feuille d'impôts je suis en
plein vol d'apollo oui pourquoi ne sais
pas vous mais terre c'est la première
fois que je déclare mes impôts les
autres années il faisait pas de
déclarations
beaucoup ont fait leur une cette année
parce que j'ai gagné cette année je ne
suis pas imposable
il ya un fond un net bond alors haut à
gauche sauf département oui ces
départements mais tu es un département
ah bon mais lequel
ça ça dépend de vous si vous écrivez
largement internautes département cours
si vous écriviez ciré un autre
département l'on a c'est comme ça il
faut que ça fasse propres ah bon on va
alors je vais mettre un un quoi bahin le
département alain il faut mettre son
prénom nom prénom c'est après façon je
m'appelle par alain alors mettez var var
d'accord la cabine
quelles communes la commune du var vous
êtes n'aime pas cheminer dans le var je
suis né dans l'ain alors mettez brest
brest
ah non non non non non non or il ya je
confond deux jours les deux forment ici
vous avez un nom capitale
j'ai un nom capitale l'homme était un
nom capital qu est-ce qu ami jimmy
colbert colbert moi j'aimais destin il
est censé l'avenir le prénom paul 6
pourquoi si pas parce que je suis le
sixième d'une famille de six garçons
s'appellent football heureusement il
s'est parlé on y en a eu 13 dates de
naissance 515
non je vous en prie ne plaisantais par
mon vieux parfois c'est une belle
victoire française donc c'est possible
mais que si vous allez payer comme
rappel et j'avais pas pensé à ça votre
réponse aux mondiaux pensent pour
allonger mai 1937
c'est plus mauvaise foi lieu de
naissance à l'exposition forcément
réservé au parc d attractions
nationalité alors yougoslave par ma mère
est douteuse par mon père mettez anglais
anglais
profession moules marinières bon j'ai
dit profession je suis moules marinières
et où ça aux folies bergère dans le
tableau des fruits de mer
je skie moules marinières moi j'aimerai
vous voir un dimanche en matinée mais
alors ne venez pas après 5 heures parce
que je me refaire d'accord et il
apportera du persil s'aimer vous fait ça
toute la journée
non le matin je subodore ah oui changez
pas de couleurs maintenant à mes débuts
au dos et plus à nous ce qu'est pour
leur piquer bon alors ensuite ouvert
audrey carte d'identité pour les
étrangers n'est pas étrange vous êtes
anglais avant il cherche à oublier c'est
pas une nationalité c'est un quart
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
numéro d'immatriculation à la sécurité
sociale
j'en ai porte ça n'avait pas alors je
n'ai pas le médecin 19 12 1 19 12 bon
d'accord mais qu'est ce que c'est c'est
de dire c'est dimanche dernier j'ai
gagné
oui dans le désert tous les shows sont
tombés et une barrière départ bon alors
à situation de famille c'est très simple
répondez par oui ou par non à passer ça
alors il vous célibataire oui elle vous
marier oui elles votent oui elle vous
divorcez oui avez vous des enfants non à
une défaillance
ce jour là j'étais malade ah oui mais
vous avez des enfants adoptifs à votre
charge prix alors indiqué la map à cette
place mamede vous préférez alors rions
ramos et gezim armistice mardi gras mi
carême bas ça va ça va je n'ai pas
yvonne non ça ferait bizarre
bon alors vous tourner la page et lola
vous avez revenu imposable profession
exercée par vous alors je remets bedous
mais cette fois sans h
mais je mets un thé comme vous êtes en
grève un sénateur oui bon alors nom et
adresse de votre employeur
c'est le directeur des folies berchère
c'est pas possible je vous pressez pas
possible parce qu'on veut pas être beau
dos aux folies bergères ça même avec des
plumes ça ne passe pas ce n'est pas
parce qu'on danse tout nus qu'on n'a pas
de religion oui c'est possible mais à
bordeaux n'a pas sa place dans un lieu
frivole mesbah alors la démocratie est
un vain mot on verra ça plus tard en
plus des trucs là maintenant mais
qu'est-ce que jamais comme un employeur
- monseigneur fait le temps avant mon
seigneur fait le pain l'adresse ce drame
de paris paris ils trouveront pas toutes
façons ce rez-de-chaussée alors on suit
traitements indemnités émoluments sommes
touchés en 62 kg vous tous chers 62 27
francs anciens noms nouveaux jeux
records pour rien au monde et brouillard
mais des 27 points à 27 ans voilà
avantages en nature à kessoua me voilà
moi je me tire in du chef terrine du
chèque oui à noël à me faire une terrine
du chef alors je m'étire une du chef à
bord et ben alors moi je m macro vin
blanc va m'aider marois alors si c'est
en boîte vous ne comptez pas la clé
bon déduction des frais professionnels
mais avant il ya bien total des gains
zaki qui n'est pas japonais n'ont alors
vous additionnez les sommes touchées en
60 de plus les avantages en nature
ce qui nous donne 27,3 macro vin blanc
voilà alors déduction des frais
professionnels ta dire bah moi j'ai
déduit depuis mon thermomètre mais vous
faites comme métier ou du mannequin au
thermomètre
ok avant ce qui va lâcher des
thermomètres pas vous présenter ça
commence sous le bras ah bon
bon ben moi je vais déduire le prix de
ma coquille de moule à la coquille de
moule et la calotte de me donner la
calotte veut novatrice il déduit une
paire de kalaba m'étais l'honneur alors
fois les pieds alors dos au total vous
allez déduire 20%
oui c'est à dire 27.3 maquereaux au vin
blanc même que 10 de moules et une paire
de calotte x 20 / sens voilà enfin
écouter j'y vais je me jette à l'eau
passé vous jeter à l'eau compte
élaboration à l'essai voilà ça nous
ferait disent être en virgule un bedeau
au vin blanc doux est immangeable de
daudelin que leur compte et vous avez dû
vous tromper l'arrière il ne faut pas
fraudé attention oh oui j'oubliais été
dur lesquels elle en retire des calottes
voyons ce que ça donne ça nous fait 17
francs 1,1 me donne une tête au vin
blanc
voilà alors de ce total vous allez
déduire encore 20% ou encore avec vous
le demande pour le versant ainsi 10%
dames en blanc annoncée rapidement si
vous dans vos jeunes ajouté
on va ça par exemple et paris me doivent
trois semaines aux baléares
[Musique]